جديد اعلنت كوريا الشماليه ان صاروخا
فضائيا يحمل قمرا اصطناعيا للاستطلاع
العسكري اطلقته صباح الاربعاء تحطم في
البحر بسبب خلل فني بحسب ما فادت وكاله
الانباء المركزيه الكوريه الشماليه وقالت
الوكاله اطلاق الصاروخ الجديد شوليما واحد
فشل بسبب عدم استقرار المحرك ونظام الوقود
في الصاروخ من ادى الى سقوطه في البحر
واكدت ان بيونغيانج ستجري تحقيقا معمقا في
العيوب التي تم اكتشافها خلال اطلاق القمر
الاصطناعي وستجري عمليه اطلاق الثانيه في
اسرع وقت ممكن وقد نشر الجيش الكوري
الجنوبي صورا قال انها لحطام الصاروخ
الفضائي الكوري الشمالي وقال الجيش انه
انتشل هذا الحطام من البحر على بعد 200
كيلومتر غرب جزيره التي تقع قباله الساحل
الغربي لكوريا الجنوبيه